[Music]
in inequality news all submitted by [ __ ]
quality I hate that [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
submitted by Bubba the Staffie what's
that a dog oh is it
Oh what kind of dog poo Marine
Staffordshire Terrier oh I have no idea
yeah that's a pit bull I'm sick there's
actually three different subspecies that
make up a pit bull and that's one of
them was a terrier called as that bull
terrier wants a Staffordshire just kind
of sorrowful are scars yeah there's a
third one off God's call Wow we should
do trivia together we'd really do I used
to really love dogs but also good and
good up against [ __ ] Harvard is being
sued for rating Asian American
applicants unfairly I've seen them I see
my [ __ ] I think I sent this to you or
you said to me maybe you should let me
because you're Larry to Bob huh I don't
know maybe no we've been talking about
you yeah I forgot it was a while ago
though before the news like went crazy
about it this is a good thing we have
too many Asians doing nerdy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's true what do you want Asians
going to jail dragons on this show dude
the reason why JK exists is because
thanks for the economy we couldn't get
jobs if the economy was great we
wouldn't be here so that means more
[ __ ] talented more Asians can who
don't get into Harvard then they're
gonna open up [ __ ] YouTube channels
and do well we're gonna start thinking
they're creative again yeah I'm just too
optimistic man people are gonna hate me
for my tea
Harvard has been under fire for this and
it's not only Harvard it's like all the
other super prestigious schools because
like what Brown University oh I believe
Chris why do you need to know that why
it's if I know she doesn't know the
answer I just want to come I won't just
want to do a conversation but she
doesn't know
answer you earn you already notions she
says she does you just made a look dawn
literally said why do you need to know
that and you literally said because I
know she doesn't know the answer that's
he you just said I don't know but then
the point is I'm trying to make the
conversation like swimming with chip
because she doesn't get to have a
conversation with an idiot all right and
that is the point but let me think what
I do know so they are saying that
Harvard MIT us because I let me cook
smart what do you notice
so Harvard scores applicants on five
different categories academic
extracurricular athletic personal and
overall and so they're saying that
whites have been getting a higher
personal rating than asian-americans
because apparently they're saying that
21.3% of white applicants are getting a
one or two compared to seventeen point
six percent of Asian Americans they're
pretty much keeping asian-americans
scores low with the whole personality
part so it's a deliberate thing yeah
that's that's what I heard they couldn't
justify it on any metric so they started
to say just like his personality base
symmetric splice objective metric but
they're killing it metrics wise they're
just doing well so it's like so they
went around an interview they're like oh
wow sob story sucks this and this they
get there like week we we have too many
agents how do we get less agents oh I
know
personality-wise will smooth like this
more can because most undergrad don't do
that abuse oh I don't know oh yeah they
do do well they do there's only guys
farmer bro okay you know it doesn't cuz
like I I kind of agree with that because
that's also hot job interviews work
right uh uh there's an entire like
personality whether I can't thing what
are you saying is like yeah you can have
be stacked on paper but if you're an
unlikable person people to want to work
with you but you're agreeing with them
that that's a genuine Joe but they're
not unlikable they're just [ __ ] doing
it so they limit how many Asians yeah
forget in but is that what it's not
it's not like oh this guy has a shitty
personality it's like this guy's Asian
I'm gonna say he has a sheen it's like
this guy's a mouth breather and he
stares and he doesn't back so I think
what Dave is trying to say is he's
trying to say the system and grading is
cool but the way they're doing is [ __ ]
up yeah and so like that's why everyone
agrees upon meet the person and they're
like what this scandal is about is the
deliberate [ __ ] intention to to mark
them off not because you know their
personality is really sucky then it
wouldn't be you know but they're like oh
well we got too many Asians so that's
nice and why do they need to have so
much diversity because then it just
looks like they're being biased or what
yes I'm either trying to avoid too much
diverse um because they're versus our
strengths geo and diversity makes us
stronger geo so this is this is they are
terribly so this is episode this is this
is what this is what I think is going on
I think you know all those Ivy League
schools they have a ton of heritage and
tradition like those frats and stuff
that date back to like 1800 1700s and I
think when in the beginning when they're
giving a more diverse student population
I'll celebrate and it was a good thing
but I think once it gets to the point
where there's more Asians than its
original students which is a Kay white I
think that challenges and destroys a lot
of that crew style traditions so you
don't like the people that wear the the
are Val socks the people that wrote the
boats like that scientifical Ivy League
look and way of life old money way of
life it's like it's completely
challenging the school and I think it's
losing its tradition so I think now
they're like we got to keep a lot of
these agents out here cuz you know
winning but this isn't the first time it
happened in Harvard were diversity like
I mean back in a day when Irish and
Jewish people were getting into higher
Harvard people were like freaking the
[ __ ] out like I'm not gonna let my kids
go to school with [ __ ] all these Jews
and [ __ ] pirates and ankles and the
blacks of their day they were but now I
mean they're a part of the old money you
know because they had to go through that
to the face of prestigious Americans are
gonna change eventually but it's just
they're going through that
now but this but I think you're right
about that is like it's like when it was
25% diverse we were cool with that but
now if we're getting overwhelmed
that's not cool we don't want to be the
minority in our own you know school that
we build I think that's basically why
which is have water then I think I think
it's more about like this Asians don't
need help and I think that it's
diversity wise like people the meme of
diversity right now is basically like
well certain people are disadvantaged
I'm not even saying disagree with that
I'm just saying certain people are
disadvantaged they need a little bit of
help to get into these colleges and
agents don't are not disadvantaged
they're not having problems getting into
these colleges so we don't need to help
them but they're doing the opposite so
is the minority that needs help and they
have reserved spots for them
Asians compete with the white kids and
they're actually pushing the Asians down
so more White's gonna win
yeah that's happening like in um and the
whole schools in hell yeah like like
high schools and people are getting
pissed off that when a bunch of Asians
move in the neighborhood the test scores
go up and their kids can't compete and
then in it they're just like what do we
you know you guys are [ __ ] it up huh
because it's very much yeah I guess it's
kind of like too much work load on their
own kids they don't want the kids to be
just focused on academics the challenges
their way of life yeah and I think
that's what it is it's too challenging
but what sucks about it is we have so
many other groups within Asians that
don't benefit from like the high income
and stuff like that like the Hmong
community we have like the Laos and the
Cambodians that are like there's a lot
of them that are low income and on
welfare and stuff and they need to
figure out a way to categorize it not
just put it into one [ __ ] group
because you have your [ __ ] parachute
babies from China that has millions of
dollars and their [ __ ] parents can
pay for all the tutoring and everything
in the world but what about all the
other kids that get lumped up like the
Southeast Asians they're like middle
class and lower middle class it's like
they they're a part of this group too so
when they really need to be a part of
that affirmative action group they don't
get that chance because all the East
Asians [ __ ] it all up so
I think that's another issue 2/3 is just
dude what's your test score didn't you
should get in that's right if it's a
hundred percent Asians I don't give a
[ __ ] that's good that's what I feel like
that's what you earned
yeah discrimination thing that was in
the news this week about this Japanese
school there's Japan's top private
school and they're like if you don't
[ __ ] like dirty underwears that you
can't get in
no they're pretty much systematically
trying to avoid women becoming doctors
oh I'll tell you this Japan's been
racist yeah but now it's like it's not a
sexist and they're open about it but
they're nice about it too trying to keep
women from becoming doctor yes they were
changing the scores like test scores on
women so they can score lower so then
they wouldn't be able to be accepted to
these schools because you changed your
desk work and yeah we don't think it's
freedom in some ways I actually like
that we're like even though it's unfair
that parts [ __ ] up I like it where
they're up front and not PC versus they
weren't up front they like this [ __ ]
cheated oh I thought they're totally up
on hey look at the chains on your test
scores yeah I love that you can respect
at least they say to your face [ __ ]
you all look that's what I like I like
if they told me straight to my face
rather than oh it's your likability and
they're like what the [ __ ] I smash the
[ __ ] out of this fool and my likeability
doesn't get me into this school right
that's weird
oh that makes you question yourself ha
yeah damn do I have social problem but
it's just straight up like yo your
school Harvard is a white school and we
got too many Asians more trouble in our
culture but a nightmare culture that's
why that's what I'm saying I like I like
it only works in Japan because it's like
95% Japanese people and it's not diverse
and they don't have to be yeah so that's
why it's like America's built on the
whole idea of like diversity melting pot
all that so then when it doesn't happen
it's like hey that's not fair yeah but I
would still prefer that because
would it be I wouldn't mind it either if
we European country was like you were a
white nation and we want to be a white
nation a lot of people are against that
but me personally I think that's fine
like why does why do all white people
have to be diverse and then share their
country even like in real life it
happens all the time I guys to get
bacon-wrapped hot dogs outside of the
Community College I was going to Los
Angeles Street Tech and I would go there
all the time with my buddy and then call
can I get two hotdogs and like six bucks
how much is one hotdog three dollars I
hear my buddy go up and ask in Spanish
and it's 200 50 cents yeah well I wasn't
Mexican dude I was getting my guy
charged there that's why I had Nicky
order everything after that Mexican oh
hell yes yeah yeah all that yo what's up
with this I'll take are you favoring him
does he speak Spanish and he's like yeah
okay well that clears all up being all
sneaky about it that I'm like what the
[ __ ] it makes me feel like--that's that
I love the discrimination of I like they
look at me and they go he's probably
rich and then I'm like I'm getting so
discreet against your traveling on a
budget - right but they're like oh he's
[ __ ] ball and I know a little funny
how like our stereotypes are all
technically positive hey new agent
aren't you good at math actually like
really smart so bad that's why when
Asian activists cry about stereotypes in
the [ __ ] that we got I'm like what are
you talking about you you're sure - I'm
sure
hood is oh we can't drive I'm like shut
the [ __ ] I make all the cars when
there's real [ __ ] going down like people
getting killed and stuff like that
that's when I'm like yeah I could back
that up because that's something to cry
about that's some crazy [ __ ] right yeah
but if it's like hey man and people are
making fun of us because like you know
we can't drive drive a Mercedes good
it's like that yeah
[Music]